mathieu kassovitz pourquoi est-ce que
vous êtes metteur en scène c'est un
moyen de se faire de l'argent très
facilement et on travaille pas vous
parfois comme un film culte
une image vous colle à la peau kassovitz
évidemment c'est le réalisateur c'est la
haine c'est aussi la rage et la
rébellion se moque de savoir ce que l'on
pense de lui
moi en tant que spectateur je ne vais
pas voir les films français est ce qu
ils font chier mais ça c'est mon point
de vue le spectateur personnel
ses coups de gueule ses coûts' en face
aux injustices et polémiques qu'il peut
provoquer sur les réseaux sociaux
son cinéma révolte et provocateur on
finit de parfaire l'image subie au
réalisme sans doute assumer d'un homme
et d'un cinéaste en colère
seul contre tous on peut dire que c'est
un homme en colère après bah quand on
connaît le plus mieux dans un team comme
c'est mon cas des gens qui l'entourent
il faut nuancer sa une du patient en
colère que ça c'est l'homme public c'est
l'image publique qu'il dégage metteur en
scène surdoué acteurs contrarier
talentueux quand il s'agit de cinéma
mathieu kassovitz et comme sur un ring
d'entraînement entier se battant sans
relâche toujours debout jusqu'à
l'épuisement total
j'ai un faisceau beaulac mathieu c'est
la colère ces conditions c'est le même
homme d'ambition scène une espèce de
sincérité d'honnêteté et de pas vouloir
rentrer dans le moule une espèce de
folie qui fait du bien quoi on peu peur
de rien hamada ben amor king mathieu
kassovitz
unique en son genre mathieu kassovitz
fascine irrite ne laisse personne
indifférent alors comment comment ce
réalisateur culte incontournable
parvient presque sans le faire exprès à
réussir une carrière d'acteur
exceptionnel au revoir quand enfin senna
avec les biens je prends
[Musique]
mathieu kassovitz à 11 ans il vient de
tourner dans le film de son père peter
kassovitz au bout du bout du banc ça
m'amène à parler à matière quel âge as
tu entendu il est très dissipée dans le
monde
dans le film pour tourner des annonces
est ce que tu veux alors devenir acteur
professionnel pour mathieu kassovitz le
métier d'acteur n'a jamais été un rêve
le cinéma il le conçoit le désir
l'observent amoureusement à travers
l'objectif d'une caméra
césar est attribué à mathieu kassovitz
nous sommes en 1995
mathieu kassovitz remporte le césar du
meilleur espoir masculin pour son rôle
dans le premier film de jacques audiard
mais le lauréat est aux abonnés absents
l'idée part à mathieu il a dit qu'il
voulait faire une carrière de
réalisateur ait pas de comedia et
commence mal parce que sa carrière de
comédien et de puissance
c'est donc jacques audiard qui ira
chercher la récompense à la place de son
comédien récalcitrants là je sais pas je
n'y a pas écrit porter mathieu mais tu
peux venir le prendre chez moi si tu
veux
en tout cas je te remercie d'avoir été
aussi bon dans mon film
franchement je m'y attendais pas
étourdissant mathieu kassovitz la même
année il prend tout le monde de court
avec la n1 deuxième long métrage dont le
succès imprévisible va surprendre
jusqu'au producteur du film on peut pas
s'imaginer que le film va faire 2
millions centre est et ils se financent
un peu contre difficilement parce qu'ils
en noir et blanc il n'ya pas d'acteurs
connus et c'est sur la banlieue
le prix de la mise en scène la haine de
mathieu kassovitz
[Applaudissements]
n'a pas la sensation qu'on est en train
de faire un film qui va faire le tour du
monde qui va choper le prix de la mise
en scène à cannes on ne peut pas
s'imaginer tout ça je vais remercier mon
père et ma mère mon père parce qu'il m'a
appris à l'aimer a pris tout ce que la
mise en scène et et puis voilà je
remercie ma mère c'est la fête des mères
à aujourd'hui
merci de ton et dont le succès est tel
qu il part aux états unis mais dans un
pays où le producteur est roi les
méthodes de ce réalisateur entêté ne
passe pas ce cas drôle c'est que sur un
tournage de mathieu s'était pas du tout
vous toujours facile parce qu'on voit un
peu dans chacune kassovitz mais on
s'ennuie jamais quoi oublier la
production c'est moi six mois le patron
si la production te dis non ça ça ne
marche pas ça cd4 d'aujourd'hui en fait
ils poussent tout le temps il veut pas
qu'on se repose ces dépassements le défi
jamais jamais satisfaire de quelque
chose et d'essayer toujours plus haut
j'aimerais vraiment le sentiment qu'il
ya une peur de se reposer pôle enfance
et puis démolie par la critique pour son
film assassins en quelques années
kassovitz a tout connu grave ou critique
est aussi le figaro assassin le film le
plus nul depuis l'invention du cinéma
voilà tout est dit depuis l'échec
commercial de l'ordre et la morale en
il a mis de côté la réalisation et
le cinéma français
je dis ça depuis que j'ai 23 ans alors
aujourd'hui il ya twitter ça j'avais pas
compris que ça ça allait changer les
choses mais c'est surtout pour donner un
coup de pied au cul aux gens les je
m'excuse évidemment au cinéma français
s'ils existent je ne je n'ai aucune
intention de se déguiser
oui malgré l'étiquette d'enfant terrible
du cinéma français kassovitz le comédien
affiche une filmographie impressionnante
construit presque malgré lui sans calcul
n'était pas je veux juste faire des
rôles de sao des rôles de ça tu prends
le scénario on t'envoie et puis et
espère en fait tu as tu choisi battait
rolls et les commerces et les
réalisateurs elle choisit ses rôles
pourtant
malgré un tableau de chasse conséquent
spielberg audiard haneke soderbergh
kassovitz n'a que peu de considération
pour la profession de comédien
personne ne parle du métier d'acteur
comme lui pour lui un type qui attend
trois heures qu'après se met devant une
caméra qui dit son texte et qui repart
ça n'a pas vraiment de valeur je pense
que pour lui travailler c'est souffrir
travailler c'est s'engager travailler
c'est transpirer sait y mettre de la
peine
preuve à l'appui avec sparring dans ce
long métrage de samuel jouy kassovitz y
incarne un boxeur besogneux qui
collectionne les défaites
un héros tendrement raté qui m'a plu
c'est que l'univers que j'ai découvert
de la boxe et des boxeurs j'ai retrouvé
ça d'une manière très juste dans le
scénario et et en plus il parle de
quelque chose qui me qui moi me touche
personnellement qui est la capacité de
faire de vivre sa passion même sans
talent et de ne pas être numéro un le
numéro un
mathieu kassovitz y est frotté d'un
sparring il partage l'affiché avec lui
puisque souleymane mbaye ancien champion
de boxe effectué là ses grands débuts au
cinéma acteurs pour moi je ne suis pas
mais je suis un compétiteur
ça veut quand il je devais faire des
scènes et à une traité de chèvre
forcément mon esprit compétiteur et des
ah bon ok on va voir on savait qu'on
pouvait aider l'autre chacun dans son
domaine
moi j'avais vraiment besoin d'elle en
boxe mais moi j'estime qu'un comédien
n'a pas vraiment besoin d'être en tant
que comédien chacun se débrouiller et
c'est tellement basique et simple que
j'étais très surpris de voir que sous
les avait le trac sur le tournage tandis
que tandis que tandis qu'il a affronté
des choses beaucoup plus importantes
beaucoup plus grave est beaucoup plus
dangereuse que quand je voyais bien
c'était comme ça genre tu peux compter
sur moi tu peux y aller pour faire les
sacs sacs de frappe j'en ai plein à la
salle je pensais
je pense à qui
charles bock sage et tu vois je prends
des coups je pars un sac si aujourd'hui
il subsiste l'acteur toujours juste
impeccable
le metteur en scène et lui silencieux
depuis sept ans difficile impossible
même pour tout cinéphile de ne pas se
désole de devoir faire le deuil du
réalisateur revue je comprends vous
soyez désolé mais c'est comme ça je
comprends mais j'en ai rien à
ah c'est comme ça que tu nous parles je
suis désolé les gars et pour voir parce
que j'ai ma vie et vous avez la vôtre
même si grâce changer de faire autre
chose as tu transpires ans explique
normand vérone mais puisqu'elle ma vie
en tant qu'acteur que ça me casse les
couilles ce qui est là mais pourquoi je
suis avec toi pourquoi tu continues par
la boxe je re box eurent fait ouais
voilà c'est beaucoup